hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
Monday the 27 februari today and you're
watching games but last week we found
out a destiny player opened up the PS
will share Play functionality to a
stranger who then proceeded delete two
of his high level characters and the
drama is continuing a video of the
incident where player calculor night HD
had two of his characters wiped by a
player named kermit the frog went viral
as you can imagine seeing hours of play
go down the drain with the click is
enough to make any gamer wins but some
have taken to verbally abusing the
offender of the PSN game informer
reports that the 23 year old who deleted
the save files was apparently hopped up
on pain medication from a prior car
accident according to his mother and
says he didn't actually do the deed
himself and that someone must have used
his account whatever the truth of it is
the 11 year old victim seems to have
made his peace with it just like I had
to at his age after a tragic neopets
accident basically don't trust the
internet xbox exec aaron greenberg was
asked whether he thought the xbox one
was released at the right time greenberg
explained on the inner circle podcast
that despite microsoft's early lon
stumbled it was the right time for them
to launch he also said that both
Microsoft and Sony were bound to have
some early successes failures greenberg
added that he thinks the xbox one was a
more ambitious console than its ps4
rival explaining quote we were trying to
do a lot more if you think about
connecting voice and TV integration we
had perhaps a more ambitious vision but
with that said no no one has ever said
that we shouldn't have launched when you
did greenberg also highlighted that this
is the first time Microsoft and Sony
have launched new generation consoles
head-to-head at the same time which
creates a tip
dynamic and star citizen is still having
money for an at it if you can believe it
the latest milestone being 73 million
popsicle extra million dollars in a
little over two weeks from its last
milestone and it seems that creator
chris Roberts hope of eventually sitting
100 million may not be so far-fetched
developer cloud imperium games recently
detailed the game's elaborate mining
system where you can search for and mine
valuable minerals in space as a
self-sustaining profession I'm guessing
it's probably going to be a little more
complicated than the normal DS
combination of scanners and curves
though currently star citizen's funding
sits up just over 70 3.5 million let me
know down in the comments if you have
any sympathy for the destiny player
whose face but deleted and if you've
ever had a tragic save file accident you
can head to gain spot where we've got
news on 4 to 6 and drive club drama
that's all the stuff that I've got for
you today but i'll have more you same
time tomorrow so be sure to check back
soon